I would say the hardest thing about  dating when you're bigger is like okay  if I go on a date with someone and you  know everything about me already it's  just kind of awkward like okay it's  different if we both have followings  because then I can equally creep on you  the same way you can creep on me but if  I go on a date and you're like oh like I  see the coffee now you drink coffee  every morning and your coffee thoughts  it's like  I I know it's not creepy because I put  it on the internet but it feels like  that so I would say that's the that's  the main thing like it's different if  you're both in that position because  then you can it's kind of like equal  playing field but I don't know and it's  just one-sided it's kind of hard